la situación realmente es un poco lo que
contaba ayer el jefe de las fuerzas
terrestres ucranianas que decían que
tenían una mínima parte de la ciudad
mínima parte significa una calle
realmente al el perímetro A las afueras
de la ciudad los soldados ucranianos que
están en las zonas tuvimos en chasipear
en Constantinopla dicen que ellos ya no
tienen el control realmente de bacmut
urbana aseguran además que la ciudad
como la han venido mostrando en esos
videos que capturan los drones está
absolutamente destruida y que no existe
y lo que sí vimos Es realmente lo que
cuentan estas tropas ucranianas que
están en esta contraofensiva A los
alrededores de la ciudad especialmente
en el norte y en el sur oeste de la
ciudad donde han ido avanzando poco a
poco pero sin embargo los
enfrentamientos son bastante grandes
donde estábamos había un gran desataques
de artillería no solamente del lado
ucraniano hacia dentro de la ciudad sino
al contrario y también Otro aspecto esta
mañana es La retirada de algunos
elementos tácticos es decir
tanques gratis de la zona de backmud no
sabemos hacia qué lado la lleva el
ejército ucraniano pero también nos
contaban quienes están allí que los
están reforzando y que están esperando
otras brigadas que vendrían a apoyarlos
en esta contraofensiva en la búsqueda
como usted decía de cercar bacmut
prácticamente como decía ayer el general
Alexander cersky propósito de este tema
Catalina Ucrania dice que efectivamente
Busca un cerco táctico de las tropas
rusas en bahamut Cómo se ve esta
estrategia desde terreno y que se espera
Bueno desde terreno Sí se ve realmente
el movimiento de tropas las brigadas que
están tanto en el norte como en el
suroeste realmente confirman que están
realizando estos avances realmente son
avances lentos en algún momento en el
primer momento se hicieron rápido pero
luego las tropas rusas han venido
reforzando esos frentes lo que ha hecho
más difícil realmente conseguir esos
avances Pero ellos son bastante
optimistas Ellos dicen que esta nueva
etapa podrá traer resultados realmente
todos allí hablan de ese cerco de bacmut
Sin embargo lo que también están a la
expectativa Es ver lo que lo que va a
pasar si realmente esas tropas Wagner se
retiran del centro de la ciudad Cuáles
son las brigadas que Rusia trae Cuál es
realmente ese refuerzo que traen allí
pero sin embargo lo que sí podemos ver y
lo que veíamos también en las pantallas
que capturaban los drones estuvimos en
de las bases de estas brigadas que nos
mostraban lo que ellos veían en el
terreno Y son terrenos totalmente
arrasados totalmente no solamente ya los
alrededores totalmente totales
enfrentamientos y cada kilómetro cada
metro que ellos van capturando tienen
que revisarlo con los drones para ver si
no quedan
algunas tropas rusas allí aunque como
decía realmente son optimistas Aunque la
tristeza de todo lo que se vivió en
durante estos diez meses los hombres que
perdieron todo lo que vivieron queda en
los rostros de algunos de estos hombres
con los que hablábamos esta mañana